präsenter generalsekretär
sehr geehrte delegierte botschafter und
politische führer dieser welt
sieben jahrzehnte der geschichte hat
dieser sei schon erlebt mit allem
reichtum und anderen drama die damit
verbunden
hier hat die welt branche gehört von
präsidentin von premierminister auf der
höhe des kalten krieges haben wir erlebt
sie nationen gegründet wurden
wir haben erlebt wie ein verbots für
mehrere führer jesus wochen haben wir
haben mehr menschen hier gehört die uns
mit hoffnung gefüllt helden die uns mit
ihrem mut beflügelt haben alle waren
hier und haben gesprochen ihre pläne und
visionen vorzustellen ihre ideen über
und zwar auf der größten bühne der welt
wie diejenigen die vor uns sich hier
getroffen haben ist auch unsere zeit
geprägt von großen herausforderungen und
klaren entscheidungen zu treffen sind
die spaltung die weltweit diesen
planeten es spaltet ist einmal mehr hier
spürbar die spaltung zwischen denen
deren streben nach kontrolle sie glauben
lässt sie dürften über andere herrschen
und auf der anderen seite den nationen
die nur über sich selbst herrschen
wollen
ich habe das unglaubliche privileg heute
für ihn sprechen zu dürfen als der
gewählte führer einer nation die die
freiheit die unabhängigkeit und die
selbstregierung der menschen vor allem
anderen schätzt die usa haben bereits
zweieinhalb milliarden dollar seit
meiner
weil ausgegeben um unser großartiges
militär wieder aufzubauen
die usa sind auch die mächtigste nation
der welt bei weitem die mächtigste und
wird hoffentlich diese macht nie
einsetzen müssen amerikaner wissen dass
in einer welt in der andere andere
unterdrückten und beherrscht und erobern
wollen unsere nation stark sein muss
den reichtum in militärischer kraft und
im geistiger kraft deswegen parteilich
verteidigen die usa die traditionen und
gewohnheiten die uns zu dem gemacht
haben was wir sind wie mein geliebtes
land hat jede nation die hier vertreten
ist eine eigene geschichte eigene kultur
ein eigenes erbe die es wert sind
verteidigt zu werden und gefeiert zu
werden und die uns unser potenzial und
unsere stärke geben die freie welt muss
die nationalen grundlagen wieder fördern
und nicht versuchen die nationalen
grundlagen zur auszuradieren oder zu
ersetzen
wenn wir uns anschauen was auf der welt
geschieht dann sehen hier auf diesem
großartigen planeten doch eine wahrheit
die leicht zu erkennen ist wenn man
freiheit will dann muss man stolz auf
das eigene land sein wenn man der
demokratie verteidigen deine
souveränität und wenn man frieden will
dann muss man die eigene nation lieben
reiseführer setzen immer das wohlergehen
ihres eigenen volkes und ihres eigenen
landes an die erste stelle
die zukunft gehört nicht den global ist
die zukunft gehört den patrioten die
zukunft gehört souveränen und
unabhängigen nationen die ihre bürger
beschützen ihre nachbarn respektieren
und die unterschiede zu schätzen wissen
die jedes land besonders machen und
einzigartig deshalb haben wir in den usa
immer uns für auf 1
auf das programm der nationalen
erneuerung konzentriert alles was wir
tun ist darauf konzentriert die träume
und bestrebungen unserer bürger zu
fördern und ihnen die möglichkeit zu
geben diese träume zu erfüllen dank
unserer wirtschaftspolitik ist unsere
arbeitslosenquote auf dem niedrigsten
niveau seit über einem halben
jahrhundert durch massive
steuerkürzungen und streichung von
regulierungen wurden arbeitsplätze
geschaffen und zwar in historischem
tempo 6 millionen amerikaner sind jetzt
in beschäftigung die vorher keine arbeit
hatten und das in weniger als drei
jahren im letzten monat am
afroamerikaner hispanic amerikaner und
asiatischstämmigen amerikaner jeweils
den niedrigsten arbeitslosenquoten
registriert die je erreicht wurden
wir nutzen die großen energie ressourcen
unseres landes die usa sind jetzt der
größte produzent von öl und erdgas
weltweit die ihre löhne steigen die
einkommen steigen 25 millionen
amerikaner wurden aus der armut befreit
in weniger als drei jahren
während wir also die unvergleichliche
macht des amerikanischen militärs wieder
aufbauen beleben wir auch unsere
bündnisse wieder neu indem wir sehr klar
machen dass all unsere partner dass wir
von all unseren partnern erwarten dass
sie ihren fairen anteil zahlen
an den verteidigungs last die die usa in
der vergangenheit allein getragen haben
im zentrum unserer vision für die
nationale erneuerung steht eine
ehrgeizige kampagne zur reform des
internationalen handels jahrzehntelang
hat das internationale handelssystem ein
die möglichkeit geboten das böswillige
nationen dieses system ausnutzen konnten
arbeitsplätze wurden aus des autos
wurden ausgegliedert und die reichen
wurden
raich auf kosten der mittelschicht in
amerika war das ergebnis 4,2 millionen
verlorene arbeitsplätze in der
fertigungsindustrie und mehrere
milliarden dollar verlust im handels
defiziten im letzten vierteljahrhundert
die usa haben jetzt entschlossen
gehandelt um diese wirtschaftliche
ungerechtigkeit zu beenden
unser ziel ist einfach wir wollen
ausgewogene hanin handel der fähr und
reziprok ist auf gegenseitigkeit beruht
sie haben eng mit unseren partnern in
mexiko und kanada zusammen gearbeitet um
nach dadurch ein ganz neues
handelsabkommen zu ersetzen das
hoffentlich von beiden parteien im
kongress getragen wird morgen werde ich
mich mit pre minister aber aus japan
treffen um unsere eine großartiges neues
handelsabkommen unter dach und fach zu
bringen
der hat das vereinte königreich sich
darauf vorbereitet aus der eu
auszutreten habe ich deutlich gemacht
dass wir bereit sind ein
außergewöhnliches neues handelsabkommen
mit dem vereinigten königreich
abzuschließen das für beide länder große
gewinne bringen wird wir arbeiten eng
mit premierminister boys johnson
zusammen an einer fantastischen neuen
handelsabkommen
der wichtigste unterschied in amerikas
neue ansatz an den handel betrifft
unsere beziehung zu china
2001 wurde es wurde china in die
welthandelsorganisation aufgenommen
damals behaupteten unsere präsidenten
dass diese entscheidung china dazu
zwingen würde
die eigene wirtschaft zu liberalisieren
[Musik]
dinge abzuschaffen die für uns nicht zu
akzeptieren sind zum beispiel im
hinblick auf eigentum und privateigentum
und rechtsstaatlichkeit zwei jahrzehnte
später hat sich diese theorie als völlig
falsch erwiesen nicht airline dass china
sich geweigert hat die versprochenen
reformen durchzuführen ein china hat
sich für einen wirtschaftsmodell
entschieden was auf massiven
marktbarrieren büro
massiven staatlichen subventionen
währungsmanipulationen preisdumping und
anderen ungerechten maßnahmen wie etwa
dem diebstahl geistigen eigentums und
auch den stelen von handels geheimnissen
von und industrie geheimnisses in großem
maßstab
ich habe vor kurzem den ceo eines
fantastischen amerikanischen
unternehmens getroffen micron technology
den habe ich im weißen haus getroffen
micron produziert chips die in
zahlreichen elektrogeräten verwendet
werden zur förderung des fünfjahresplans
in china hat ein staatliches
chinesisches unternehmen micron
konstruktionspläne gestohlen
die mit 8 7 milliarden dollar bewertet
werden
die chinesische unternehmen hat patente
eingereicht für identische produkte und
micron wurde verboten die eigenen waren
in china zu verkaufen
aber wir wollen gerechtigkeit die usa
haben 60.000 unternehmen also 60.000
produktionschef fabriken verloren seit
dem eintritt von china in die
welthandelsorganisation dasselbe ist
anderen ländern auf der ganzen welt
geschehen die welthandelsorganisation
braucht drastische veränderungen die
zweitgrößte wirtschaft der welt sollte
des zweitgrössten wirtschaft der welt
sollte nicht erlaubt sein sich selbst
als entwicklungsland zu bezeichnen um
das system zu fälschen auf kosten
anderer
jahrelang wurde dieser missbrauch
toleriert ignoriert oder sogar ermutigt
globalismus hat einen religiösen druck
ausgeübt auf die vergangenen
präsidenten- damit sie die eigenen
nationalen interessen vergessen aber was
amerika betrifft so sind diese zeiten
vorbei
um diese unfairen praktiken zu bekämpfen
habe ich massive zelle
deklariert im umfang von über 5
milliarden dollar für chinesische waren
als ergebnis dieser zelle werden bereits
lieferketten wieder zurück verlagert
nach amerika und den anderen nationen
und milliarden dollar landen in unseren
staatskassen
das amerikanische volk bekennt sich zum
wiederaufbau ausgewogener beziehungen zu
china hoffentlich können wir eine
vereinbarung erzielen die für beide
länder
vorteilhaft ist aber ich habe sehr klar
gemacht ich werde kein schlechtes
abkommen akzeptieren was für das
engagement schlecht ist während wir uns
bemühen unsere beziehung zu
stabilisieren überwachen wir auch
sorgfältig die situation in hongkong
verfolgen was dort geschieht
die welt erwartet dass die chinesische
regierung sich an den vertrag hält der
mit den räten damals abgeschlossen wurde
und der bei der un registriert wurde um
das die demokratischen rechte und das
rechtssystem in hongkong zu schützen und
zu respektieren wie er sich entscheidet
diese situation zu regeln wird sehr viel
aussagen über die rolle chinas in der
welt auch in zukunft wir bauen auf
präsident china als großen führer die
usa wollen keinen konflikt mit
irgendeiner anderen nation
wir wollen frieden zusammenarbeit und
gegenseitig gewinnbringende
vereinbarungen aber ich werde es nie
versäumen amerikas interessen zu
verteidigen
eine der größten sicherheitsbedrohungen
für friedliebenden nationen ist heute
das repressive regime im iran
die bilanz des regimes in sachen tod und
zerstörung ist uns allen wohl bekannt
nicht nur ist ihr rahmen der wichtigste
förderer des terrorismus weltweit irans
führer bevor er die tragischen kriege in
syrien und jemen gleichzeitig
klünder das regime den wohlstand des
eigenen landes aus um atomwaffen und
atomraketen sich anzuschaffen das dürfen
wir nie geschehen lassen
wir müssen iran auf dem weg zu halten
ich kenne die vereinten nationen eine
schreckliche atom abkommen mit dem iran
wir haben nicht viel zeit der iran hat
inspektionen wichtige standorte nicht
erlaubt und hat auch ballistische
raketen nicht einbezogen nachdem wir
ausgetreten sind haben wir weitreichende
wirtschaftliche sanktionen verhängt
in der hoffnung sich von den sanktionen
zu befreien hat das regime seine
gewaltsame licht provozierte aggression
verstärkt nach dem jüngsten angriff des
iran auf die ölanlagen in saudi arabien
haben wir verschärfte sanktionen gegen
die zentralbank des iran und andere
bereiche dieser art verengt alle
nationen müssen tätig werden keine
verantwortungsbewusste regierung darf
den iran dieses blutrünstige regime
unterstützen solange dieses bedrohliche
verhalten fortbesteht werden die
sanktionen nicht aufgehoben sie werden
verschärft werden
die führung des iran hat eine stolze
nation verwandelt
das ist eine geschichte die man sich
merken muss was geschieht wenn eine
herrschende klasse gegen das eigene volk
vorgeht und persönliche macht anstrebt
und den reichtum vor augen hat 40 jahre
lang hat die welt das erlebt 40 jahre
lang haben wir den herrschern des iran
zu gehört die sich gegen alle anderen
gewandt hatten obwohl sie selbst die
probleme geschaffen hat tod amerika
hatte man gerufen
ein schrecklicher antisemitismus wurde
verbreitet der oberste führer des landes
bezeichnete fry letztes jahr als
krebsgeschwulst das beseitigt werden
müsse und ausgelöscht werden müsse
das ist möglich dass wir zu kommen
aber amerika wird diesen antisemitismus
lieber auf stunden fanatiker haben den
hass auf israel genutzt um von der
eigenen schwächen in eigenen versagen
abzulenken
gott sei dank gibt es immer mehr
klarheit weltweit in breiteren in
größeren nahen osten
dass die staaten der region gemeinsame
interessen haben im kampf gegen den
extremismus in der nutzung
wirtschaftliche chancen
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
normalisierter beziehungen haben
zwischen israel und seinen nachbarn nur
eine beziehung auf der grundlage des
gegenseitigen respekts und religiösen
toleranz kann uns weiterbringen
die bürger des iran haben eine regierung
verdient der daran gelegen ist armut
abzubauen korruption zu beseitigen
arbeitsplätze schaffen statt dem voll
geld zu stehlen um etwas zu finanzieren
um morde im ausland und im inland
durchzuführen nach vier jahrzehnten des
versagens sollten die iranischen führer
abtreten sollten damit aufhören andere
staaten zu bedrohen und sollten durch
punkt darauf legen ihr eigenes land
auszubauen es ist zeit dafür dass die
führung des iran endlich das iranische
volk an die erste stelle setzt amerika
ist bereit für freundschaft mit allen
einzutreten
die wirklich nach frieden nach achtung
streben viele der engsten freunde
amerikas waren einstmals unsere
schlimmsten feinde
die vereinigten staaten haben nie an
dauerhafte freundschaft geglaubt wir
wollen partner keine gegner mega weiß
dass jeder kriege führen kann das aber
nur die mutigsten sich für den frieden
entscheiden können aus eben diesem grund
haben die eine kühne diplomatie auf der
koreanischen halbinsel betrieben ich
habe kim jong-un dazu gesagt was ich
wirklich glaube sein land wie der iran
hat ein gewaltiges nicht genutztes
potenzial um diese verheißungen zu
erfüllen muss nordkorea aber auf
atomwaffen verzichten unsere botschaft
ist weltweit klar das ziel amerikas ist
harmonie
das ziel liegt nicht darin dass wir
endlose kriege haben kriege die nie zu
ende gehen
das wollen wir nicht wir haben das vor
augen und meine administration ist
dementsprechend auch daran gelegen eine
lichtere zukunft für afghanistan zu
erreichen
leider haben die taliban sich
entschieden ihre schlimmen angriffe
fortzusetzen
wir werden mit unserer koalition
afghanischer partner zusammenarbeiten
auch weiterhin um den terrorismus
auszulöschen und wir werden nie aufhören
frieden als realität anzustreben
auf der westlichen in der westlichen
hemisphäre arbeiten wir mit unseren
partnern an chancen in der gesamten
region die benutzen wollen
eine unserer größten aufgaben ist dabei
das problem der illegalen einwanderung
die durch wird der wohlstand untergraben
die gesellschaft wird zerrissen
kriminelle kapelle machen sich breit und
es kommt zu einer massiven illegalen
einwanderung das ist nicht fair
das ist nichts sicher das ist nicht
nachhaltig durchzuführen
bei allen beteiligten die länder die
ihre bevölkerung verlieren und das ist
ein schneller prozess sind betroffen und
kümmert sich nicht um die jugendlichen
dort und menschliches kapital wird
vergeudet die aufnahmeländer sind
überfordert mit immer mehr einwanderer
als die verantwortungsbewusst übernehmen
könnten und auch die einwanderer werden
ausgebeutet angegriffen und missbraucht
von bösartigen menschen fast ein drittel
der frauen die in den norden gehen
werden sexuell belästigt
auf ihrem weg dorthin in den vereinigten
staaten und weltweit gibt es eine immer
radikalere industrie von aktivisten die
den menschenschmuggel betreiben
diese gruppierungen treten ein für
illegale einwanderung und wollen die
nationalen grenzen überwinden
ich habe eine botschaft für diese
verfechter offener grenzen
die mit dieser rhetorik antreten soziale
gerechtigkeit werde angestrebt
eure politik muss ich sagen ist grausam
und bösartig hier nächtigt kriminelle
organisationen gegen unschuldige männer
frauen und kinder vorzugehen
ihr geht gegen das leben das wohlergehen
und unschuldiger menschen vor
er untergräbt damit die sicherheit
für alle die menschenrechte und die
menschenwürde viele der staaten die
heute hier versammelt sind bemühen sich
mit den anforderungen den aufgaben der
unkontrollierten einwanderung fertig zu
werden
jeder von ihnen hat das absolute recht
die eigene grenze zu schützen und das
gilt natürlich auch für unser land
wir müssen heute uns entschließen gegen
den menschenschmuggel anzugehen
gegen den menschenhandel auch und diese
kriminellen netzwerke aus dem geschäft
trennen
für unser land kann ich ihnen aufrichtig
sagen dass wir eng mit unseren freunden
zusammenarbeiten in der region mit
mexiko kanada guatemala honduras el
salvador und panama wir wohl die
integrität der grenzen waren und für
sicherheit und wohlstand unserer
menschen sorgen
ich möchte ein präsident lópez obrador
von mexiko
dafür danken dass er so gut mit uns
kooperiert ich danke auch dafür dass er
jetzt 20 27.000 soldaten an unsere
grenze geschickt hat mexiko beweist uns
sehr viel respekt und ich erweise auch
in der anderen richtung diesen respekt
diese achtung
die usa haben noch nicht dagewesene
maßnahmen ergriffen um gegen den strom
illegaler einwanderer vorzugehen
wer illegal über unsere grenze will der
sollte folgendes höheren zahlt nichts an
die schmuggler nichts an die kojoten
bringt euch nicht selbst in gefahr
bringt eure kinder nicht in gefahr
denn wenn sie hier sind werdet ihr
gleich wieder nach hause geschickt
ihr werdet nicht in unserem land bleiben
können solange ich präsident der
vereinigten staaten von amerika bringen
so lange werden unsere gesetze gelten
und unsere grenzen geschützt werden für
alle länder der westlichen hemisphäre
liegt unser ziel darin in die lichte
zukunft der eigenen nation zu
investieren
unsere region hat so viele verheißungen
zu bieten so viele träume kann aufgebaut
werden in unseren jeweiligen staaten und
überall wartet man darauf dass diese
träume verwirklicht werden millionen
hart arbeitender patriotischer junger
menschen sind überall zu finden
die neues machen wollen die etwas
erreichen wollen
aber die zu starten können ihr potenzial
nicht nutzen wenn eine generation von
jugendlichen von zu hause weg geht auf
der suche nach irgendeinem leben
anderswo
sie wollen dass jede nation bei uns in
der region gedeiht und blüht dass die
menschen in freiheit und frieden leben
können
wir sind auch engagiert wenn es darum
geht menschen in der westlichen
hemisphäre zu unterstützen
die brutal unterdrückt werden zum
beispiel in kuba nicaragua und wenn ich
spieler nach einem aktuellen bericht des
menschenrechtsrats der nationen stehen
frauen im industrieller zehn stunden am
tag an um lebensmittel kaufen zu können
mehr als 15.000 menschen sind als
politische häftlinge festgenommen worden
todesschwadronen führen tausende
außergerichtlicher hinrichtungen durch
diktator maduro ist ein puppe hoopers
marionette kubas
da steckt sich vor dem eigenen volk
während kuba die ölquellen des wählers
ausplündert um das eigene korrupte
kommunistische regime am leben zu halten
die panischen staaten unsere partner
haben eine historische koalition von 55
staaten gebildet die die legitime
regierung des wählers anerkenntnis die
dort gefangenen venezolaner deuten
wissen dass ganz amerika hinter ihm
steht vereinigten staaten schicken sehr
viel humanitäre hilfe und warten darauf
dass sie ausgeliefert werden kann
wir sehen uns die lage in wintersweiler
sie ja genau an
wir warten auf den tag an dem die
demokratie wiederhergestellt wird
an dem bin ich wieder frei sein wird und
an dem die freiheit in der gesamten
hemisphäre gelten wird eine der größten
aufgaben für unsere staaten ist das
gespenst des sozialismus sind die
zerstörung der gesellschaft die wir
erleben musst wenn die spieler erinnert
uns daran dass sozialismus und
kommunismus nicht gerechtigkeit zum ziel
haben darum geht es nicht es geht auch
nicht um gleichstellung nicht um rettung
von armen unterstützung von armen und
sicherlich auch nicht um das wohl der
jeweiligen nation den sozialismus und
der kommunismus betreffen wir eine sache
macht für die herrschende klasse möchte
eine botschaft wiederholen eine
botschaft an die welt des bauens zu
hause ausgesprochen habe amerika wird
nie ein sozialistisches land werden
der sozialismus und kommunismus haben
letzten jahrhundert 100 millionen
menschen das leben genommen
in windows wähler können wir das mit
traurigen augen sehen
dort geht es weiter auf diesem kurs
diese totalitären ideologien in
verbindung mit modernen technologien
führen dazu oder können dazu führen
neue formen der unterdrückung platz
greifen zu lassen neue formen der daher
schon ergreifen die vereinigten staaten
schritte und ausländische technologien
und investition genauer zu überwachen
und unsere daten und unsere sicherheit
zu wahren und zu schützen
wir fordern alle anwesenden nationen auf
ebenso zu handeln
freiheit und demokratie müssen ständig
bewacht und geschützt werden
im ausland wie aus dem inland heraus wir
dürfen nicht aufhören
skeptisch zu bleichen gegenüber den
jeden sie anders reden wir sehen
alarmierende zeichen neue bedrohung der
freiheit eine kleine zahl von sozialen
medien von solchen plattformen haben
eine gewaltige macht erlangt über das
was wir sehen können und was wir sagen
dürfen
politische klasse äußert sich ganz offen
abschätzig über den willen des volkes
ist eine gesichtslose bürokratie ist in
stillen tätig und wir sehen für
demokratische herrschaft untergraben
wird medien akademische institutionen
legen
beleidigungen vor beleidigen unsere
geschichte und unsere werte meine
administration in den vereinigten
staaten hat den sozialen medien und den
unternehmen dort gesagt dass wir für das
recht auf freie rede eintreten werden
eine freie gesellschaft wird nicht
zulassen dass giganten den sozialen
medien das volk verstummen lassen
freie menschen ist dürfen niemals
eingespannten für die sache dinge zu
verschweigen oder menschen zum schweigen
zu verdammen oder eigene staatsbürger zu
verleumden
hier sind wir das recht auf
menschenwürde überall auf der welt meine
organisation arbeitet mit anderen
staaten daran auch für homosexuelle
einzutreten und uns solidarisch zu
zeigen
wir treten für betroffene menschen in
homosexuellen spektrum ein die in
staaten leben wo man die sexuelle
orientierung endet und bestraft wir sind
auch uns bewusst wir veränderten rolle
der frauen in der gesellschaft
gesellschaften die frauen fördern sind
sicherer weiterentwickelt und stabiler
auf mittlere und lange sicht es ist
deshalb entscheidend nicht nur für den
wohlstand der nationen sondern auch für
die nationale sicherheit hier
weiterzukommen
wir müssen die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung der frauen voranbringen
von diesen grundsätzen geleitet hat
meine administration die weltweite
frauenförderung initiative durchgeführt
diese initiative ist die erste
regierungsinitiative zur befähigung von
frauen weltweit verstärkt tätig zu
werden ihre rechte zu vertreten besitz
zu haben in die gleichen unternehmen zu
arbeiten wie männer frei zu reisen
kredite zu bekommen institution tätig zu
werden
ich habe gestern auch führerinnen und
führer zu empfangen die sich für das
engagement die usa zum schutz von
religiösen führern einsetzen
es geht auch um den schutz der
religiösen freiheit dieses grundrecht
wird weltweit immer mehr bedroht das ist
schwer zu glauben aber 80 prozent der
weltbevölkerung leben in ländern wo die
religiöse freiheit gefährdet ist oder
gar nicht besteht amerikaner werden
niemals bei unsere bemühungen nachlassen
für die freiheit der religionsausübung
einzutreten
wie werden die religionsfreiheit für
alle verfechten amerikaner werden auch
nie müde werden unschuldige und ihr
leben zu schützen viele projekte der
vereinten nationen haben sich bemüht ein
weltweites recht auf von steuerzahlern
finanzierte abtreibungen durchzusetzen
bis zum geburtszeit punkt bürokraten in
den verschiedensten bereichen gegentor
gegen die souveränität von staaten die
unschuldiges leben schützen wollen
wie viele nationen hier glauben hier in
amerika dass jedes kind geboren wie
ungeborenen eine heilige gabe gottes ist
es gibt kein umstand unter denen die
vereinigten staaten
es zulassen werden dass internationale
interessen
die rechte für menschen die dazu trampe
einschließlich des rechtes auf
selbstverteidigung deshalb heraus in
diesem jahr erklärt dass wir niemals
dass waffen hat kommt der vereinten
nationen unterstützen werden
rechtstreuen bürger werden ihren rechten
eingeschränkt wir werden stets unser in
der verfassung verankertes recht
beibehalten waffen zu führen
entsprechend unserem zweiten
verfassungszusatz das sind die rechte
für die wir heute eintreten
das ist in den gründungsdokumenten juris
also festgeschrieben
die gründer unserer nation hatten
verstanden dass es immer diejenigen
geben wird die glauben dass sie macht
über andere ausüben wollen
dafür gibt es unterschiedliche namen und
bezeichnungen aber es läuft letztlich
auf den wunsch nach beherrschung hinaus
wir werden nicht die interessen der
vielen geschütztes und dann die
privilegien der wenigen unsere familien
hatten uns ein system gegeben mit denen
der diesen gefährlichen impuls steuern
können amerikanische macht soll an
diejenigen die für unsere nation
wirklich eintreten
ein stolzes täglich auf unabhängigkeit
bedachten volk gezielte nationen können
nur von wenigen verfolgt werden
die bürger sind die in ihre geschichte
wurzeln die von der eigenen kultur
getragen werden
an den eigenen werten hängen dem volke
dienen wert auf das liegen und die
wissen dass ihre zukunft jahren besteht
etwas aufzubauen
sonst würden sie alles verlieren
patrioten sehen die nation und ihr
schicksal auf eine art und weise wie
niemand anders
die freiheit wird nur gefahr durch
souveränität souveränität muss gesichert
werden die in kathy kang nur gewahrt
werden wenn der wille und die hingabe
von patrioten da sind hier muss der
wille da sein gegen unterdrückung
vorzugehen
sie muss der wille da sein freundschaft
anzustreben und auch die kühnheit nach
dem frieden zu verlangen und hin zu
fordern
die liebe zu unserer nation macht die
welt für alle nationen besser ich möchte
allen politischen führern hier zu rufen
dass wir uns an gemeinsamen auftrag
erfüllen müssen
der wichtigste beitrag den alle machen
können besteht darin die eigene nation
weiter wachsen zu lassen die eigene
kultur zu achten die geschichte zu ehren
die bürger zu würdigen ihre rechte zu
wahren die eigenen länder stark und
wohlhabend werden zu lassen und nicht
liegt dann außerhalb des eigenen bereich
der möglichkeiten die zukunft wird dann
für uns alle lichter aus sehen unsere
menschen werden glücklicher sein und
unsere partnerschaft mit herz stärker
werden
mit gottes hilfe werden wir die feinde
der freiheit zurückweichen und die
unterdrücker der würde bezwingen muss
wir werden neue lebensstandard festlegen
können neue höhen menschlichen strebens
erklimmen können werden neue geheimnisse
lösen neue durchbrüche erzielen und wir
werden für andere formen der
freundschaft und harmonie zwischen
nationen erlangen als je zuvor
liebe kollegen die sie ihre staaten
führen
treten wir einen für frieden und
gerechtigkeit in der ganzen welt für die
gesamte menschheit und damit müssen wir
zu hause anfangen
ich danke ihnen gott segne sie alle gott
segne die nationen der welt und gott
segne amerika
donald trump der präsident der
vereinigten staaten mit seiner rede
meine damen und herren an dieser stelle
verlassen
die live übertragung von den vereinten
nationen werden allerdings gleich
nochmals kurz nur angeschnitten hatten
die rede des brasilianers leonardo noch
einmal nach reichen und ich verweise
jetzt schon einmal darauf dass wir um 17
uhr jeremy corbijn von den britischen
labels erwarten ab 17 uhr ist die rede
angekündigt auf dem parteitag das wird
ganz spannend und mein kollege thomas
bade es dann auch für sie da und wird
sie dann in den abend begleiten ich will